hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to quick draw
so anyway quick draw is a game about
artificial intelligence so we're gonna
be given prompts and the computer is
going to interpret our doodles of those
prompts to see if it can figure it out
now the closer we are the better it
learns but I'm not good at drawing also
I've got a [ __ ] mouth
so nose house is gonna go draw dresser
in under 20 seconds got it ha
isometrically Oh legs on my line
good job you see line we on oh I know
it's dresser
yay it's a dresser I got it ok snowflake
uh can I draw myself because I'm a
beautiful unique snowflake supa dupa
dupa dupa zig zag no not a zig zag I
have no clue what you're drawing thanks
I don't play no not an airplane ork
hang on I sweetfish wait for not a fish
you can't fire aah sorry I couldn't
guess it dammit I'm stupid and bad
alright a foot hang on Chuba - woop Xu
Zhu Lewbert Oh or hand nope
or finger it's a foot or candle it's a
goddamn foot luckily broccoli AZ
strawberry it's a foot it's a [ __ ]
foot dude it's a boy it's a top-down
view of a [ __ ] fine gets it how are
you not getting this
it's Izzie alright here we go this can't
be hard Jupiter shoop shoop shoop shoot
you out you don't see a skateboard stop
guessing
god dammit poor gun but no not a gun
RINO or motorbike stop
I see basketball basketball soccer ball
it's a goddamn camera sorry I couldn't
get you are god-awful with this zigzag
is it just giving me an easier prompt
because it thinks I'm bad at drawing
which it would be absolutely correct
about oh I know it's exact there you go
you're so smart
alright I feel like I'm in kindergarten
again nicely pork you don't see a
forehead oh I know it's tree there we go
it's a tree good job I don't want to
share those drawings
nobody share those drawings nobody ever
good guy I mean the dresser is okay even
though it looks like a bedside table but
that's a goddamn camera that's a hundred
percent obviously a camera and that's on
represent objects not a snow
like I I will readily admit that is not
100% not a snowflake draw a cell phone
all right I'm gonna do a flip flown flip
flip I see square no hang on hat
hey I'm laptop no it's a phone I'm not
sure what that is 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
it's a phone Wow sorry I couldn't guess
it it's a flip phone water slide ok I
see hockey puck into a pool of water in
a wave andreen and a happy shark is here
akka dial it's got it no hang on
helicopter no no no we're bulldozer it's
a water slide here's the stairs up to
the water slide here's the stands it's
on it it's a water slide
I see sandwich it's a sandwich it was a
[ __ ] water slide
alright crayon hip hip hip hop hot lid
no hang on it's got a rounded tip there
we got we're wine bottle ray oh it's
green yeah it's got it ok it's getting
it it's not stupid it knows what it's
doing and just wants to decide not to
tempt easy ba ba ba ba ba ba
oh my god Emma it's Ted yeah alright you
got it
Raik hang on I see monkey monkey
keyboard hang on taste hair on boar
camouflage hang on I got flour it's the
rain it's the rain here it's the rain
it's obviously the rink mustache okay
got it wait for it
I see cell phone shut the [ __ ] up poor
skull it's using vats a cell phone or
beard this icy fireplace smell bad where
is that beard we're done the best
dashboard scorpion sorry I couldn't
guess it okay I get that might have been
more of a laptop but this is a hundred
percent obviously a dragon that's a
crayon
that's a tent that's the rake that's a
mustache you're [ __ ] stupid how am I
supposed to draw yoga okay all right you
know what all right I got this
hey Cassie frying pan
horse n yeah oh I know it's yoga ah yeah
okay we got this
hell yeah we're doing good I think oh my
god yes yeah uh uh oh I know
it stops up okay hang on dude RUP RUP or
dumbbell oh I know it's - yeah okay that
did not look like a tooth all right we
got this
whoopty whoopty will crying pen D whoop
Dee poor dumbbell hmm
war bicycle oh I know it's hella calm
yeah it's a helicopter you're doing so
good Oh skyscraper perfect whoop
I see live mm-hmm four matches hmm oh I
know it's skyscraper yes oh yeah door
easy peasy lemon squeeze me it's door
it's learn oh my god it's learning oh no
what are we gonna do oh god if it's
learning that means it's gonna take over
the world how can we solve this
conundrum Oh God dato hey well I know
it's potatoes that's a potato
I see headphones oh I know it's like
glasses hate eyeglasses it sure is I see
Lionel troop troop or Bush sure you see
Bush huh no it's a hand fan it's a hand
fan no it's a fan no it's it's a fan hey
I see butterfly it's a fan sorry
it's very clearly a fan saxophone okay
doo doo doo doo doo I see street life
create a new Bert mutate new for frying
pan route du du du du du du du du phone
yeah okay birthday cake all right we got
this Hobbit abou P it was Lucas this
looks like a dick cake well I know it's
birthday cake
ah all right we almost got it all hang
on keyboard shove it a ship troopship
chill - no it's keyboard I was not done
yet
I see toilet a toilet it's a lantern
it's in flux it's a lantern
it's a [ __ ] lantern guess it ah why
should he Laura we're cool quack
for snorkel quack or cannon quack horse
one quack
oh my curly duck penis a kiss god oh
okay
hurt bird I've got a draw doctor get a
bus drop ahead but Drella stork a less
of a duck that is not a duck that's it
I've done the anomaly
here's my curly duck penis there it is
look you're all right fly see Kel I I've
drawn a dragon I've turned a drag that I
didn't mean to or drawn dragon don't
know how draw a dragon with the curly
duck penis ah [ __ ]
fine so that is a quick draw I have an
idea this is kind of like pictionary
right so what if we were to go play
Pictionary with you guys would you be
able to be a better neural network than
these [ __ ] here maybe I have no
ideas but we're gonna find out so see
you then bye bye hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to quick draw
otherwise known as pictionary I just got
done playing the Google version of this
so we got this big whiteboard here we've
got some willing and subjective fans
here that we're going to draw for and if
they can guess what it is they don't get
hit with dodge balls or beaten with that
back
and that Bob rub my chest with a
whiteboard but the wrong sides kind of
gray and John wood are you ready yeah
[Music]
what is that look
what is that no no II so no what is that
it's clearly an animal cat no did you
count that round what is that close
what's the other thing thank you what
rotten mouth so then if that is that
what is that it's a big herbal is that a
big drill see the buck teeth the thing
though not quite mouse here I couldn't
have made it any clearer you know the
Kelly Pig no that's me today oh I get
rid of me all right
Martha [ __ ] almost almost
but what do I do and that was tough it
was a great youtuber oh look at the
whole picture guy wonder gun context
clue to what's going on here you sure
drunk Bob I would have gotten it all
right get you really really not what am
i doing you I'm drawing Anarkali
become fun it's obvious to some of us
and it's [ __ ] Ohio the three cities
in Ohio
you only live in sanad hello everyone
it's those horror IDs of a matter that
is a legit drawing at Ohio that is
legitimately Ohio I gave you context
clues without putting any writing in
there three major cities yeah when you
put writing in there Eddie bear yeah
tested border with Indiana I was putting
eerie cuz Lake Erie above Ohio I know
you were trying to draw the whole United
States for a minute and I was like one's
digging one state at a time
yeah no no no you had the favor but keep
on rechargers Hey running running
running running uh judges when we accept
running runner as then runner runner you
sent a runner
I don't accept I don't know I was gonna
cut you a break but no no no no no I
would to run simply the holder wait shut
up you're pretty nice snowman
Furby oh the beak is what you really
nailed yeah yeah yeah the beak is what
did the eyes and the beak well done all
right okay all right oh yes yes oh I
draw perfectly fine you are the one that
needs to pick it up because you you need
three okay that's all you guys do really
simple oh hi wait you've changed
you got handsomer Oh face it
oh thank you in the face like allow a
lot uglier now thank you for noticing
potaters phrases you got a guess from so
who's guessing on the back no I was
throwing my place going my boy did you
pick up that hit disqualified
disqualified job I just
we are the world and shot heard round
the world
oh that's a doozy
really yeah but you you could have been
with Mickey Mouse with your mouse
no but then I could have gone out to
dinners that is not good when you look
at that thing who thinks Disney I
thought princess elephant type hmm make
you I didn't you just told me for Disney
draw Mickey Mouse why that doesn't work
see what that doesn't your back big boy
I'm your Pokemon emo me you're a
horrible person you said you told me
yeah I do know I was like from me and be
mean like stuck in sweet so distract me
self-portrait dry erase board
that's so meta you just had the money
they asin's you how is that a marker it
looks like I like a taco shell which was
originally who knew that was a dry erase
board
I know yeah people laughing I think so
anyway
everyone here is a failure so now I'm
gonna prove that I'm better than
everybody
now we're gonna get volunteers ready
okay three two one go smoke Zack
umbrella a palm tree
it's a ribcage yeah just heart shot
specifically are we gong ribs sternum
ooh-ah diaphragm bone skeleton bone
skeleton ribcage towards o1x right yes
that's good that's clever idea yeah idea
uh oh hi oh mug cloudy day spongebob
yeah okay wait yeah persons Bob uh Award
winner spider-man okay
cannon penis uh wire a microphone uh
joint knee joint uh lamb cannon uh
balloon confetti a candlestick
uh sighs lion it was close
what I'd slab right know was a Bunsen
burner it was chemistry sadness ah it
was close Wow lies left a little vague
all right
rainbow moose Rock I say two eyes two
people in bed three people in bed the
three Studios on three musketeers a rock
face south face
now rest more dabbing penis spite and
smoke pipe car duck uh Swan dog lying in
bed Chigi lion bed
she can bet she could sleep in chicken
bulldog cowboy please man
uh the YMCA guy C cheerleader male
cheerleader Jack something I thought
that was his hand
that's actually exactly what his hand
looks like River Mississippi River Trail
railroad track map navigation uh party
balloon mushroom spores ah ah javelin
thrower ah boat on a river
I didn't filter this one I didn't know
what it is I still don't know
[Applause]
now what is this is this like the whole
room yeah I think it's good what no one
else it I see it yeah that makes sense
that makes sense okay are you rock uh
Freddy fazbear um is a man in a bear
suit is a man with a big feet ah guy
with a pipe got the shotgun guy with an
expert got home the buy some puzzle a
year yeah how would I've known until he
finished it I guess it after he finished
it yeah you got a drop faster Oh box
time x10 its Chester doors as a hardened
box on her tail uh I got undertale
anyway that was the end a quick draw
hope you enjoyed that
we had a ton of fun with it and we
discovered that I am way smarter than
Google but also so thank you everybody
so much for watching but we've got one
more treat Tyler is currently king of
art making his masterpieces magnum opus
I'll get one gasp I get one guess to
determine what it is maybe I don't know
I'll probably it more you have one
second what
one second you get this point - all
right Zoe am I gonna get it you are
going to get it I don't know
[Applause]
our set our office so anyway that was
good draw hope you enjoyed it thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
everybody who attended hope you had fun
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody so much for watching and as
always we will see you even the staff
fireworks
lizard what a Godzilla in the next video